[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey luke here with jason
okay tommy and nathan here are going
with me to england
look at the camera i'm going to spend 10
days car
fishing with my boys me and my family
we're going to
england and nathan and tommy and i we're
going to be doing some serious carp
fishing
all right guys go run free uh
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
so
well we finally made it i've been
traveling for 12 hours
and here we are cherry lakes the
cotswolds
in england and it is absolutely
gorgeous the weather is absolutely
perfect
couldn't ask for better
[Music]
okay
[Music]
while me and the boys were getting the
groceries bought becca and her folks
were in london
tearing it up sightseeing as much as
they could in one day
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
the name of the place we were staying at
was cherry lakes it's a beautiful
trophy carp fishing lake with these
private cottages you can rent and i'll
put a link to their website in my video
description
but they were at bait boats and rod pods
and carp fishing tents and all sorts of
really cool
car fishing gear and i absolutely had a
ball
and it didn't take me very long before i
hooked into one of their monster
carp
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
my first british carve
28 pound mirror new personal best for
mirrors
oh what a gem look what a
porker this thing here
man what a great way to start this trip
out i've been in england for
less than 24 hours and i've got a 28
pound mirror carp
on the bank it's just awesome my first
british carp
cherry lakes was just a beautiful and
ideal location for our family there's
these three private lakes with lots of
large fish in it
these cozy little cabins along the lake
you can rent including the largest one
which
fit all six of us very comfortably very
nice modern clean place to rent with a
hot tub
and a jacuzzi tub but it was also
centrally located in the cotswolds
and one of our favorite things that we
love to do in england is just
drive around the cotswolds and see the
gorgeous towns and villages
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this trip really worked out well i could
stay at the house and fish and keep an
eye on nathan while he was down for his
nap
and becca and her folks could go out
sightseeing and enjoy the countryside
[Applause]
the cost walls of england is one of the
most charming places on earth and
there's all these wonderful little
villages with these great names like
stow on the wall
then upper slaughter and one of the
places we visited was
bybre and it's a little bit more
touristy than some of the other villages
but it's got these great little trout
farms and it's absolutely scenic it
contains
some national heritage sites and it's
just a beautiful place and the kids love
to go feed the trout and we just had an
absolutely great time
hey tommy you ready to go fishing with
friends
one of the things i did on this trip was
i got to go fishing with a friend
named mark who lived in buckingham
england
and we did canal fishing which is
probably the most
english type of fishing you can do these
beautiful canals crisscross the country
with these canal boats in them and you
can just walk up and down
the canals fishing and catching carp and
bream
and roach and all sorts of wonderful
fish and
so i would have bought a couple pints of
pinkies of these little pink maggots
and we just had a ball fishing oh
oh it looks like a shad oh i've heard
that they're slimy
we gotta breathe shall we put it back in
the water put it back
wait oh yeah i got a towel
there's poop
it's coming there's poop oh
this slime
hey tommy come here boy
[Music]
after the fishing mark took us back to
his farm and let tommy play with the
baby turkeys
you like that tommy yeah he's so cute
becca's mom had never been to paris so
while me and tommy were fishing
becca and her folks took the channel to
paris and did a one day
whirlwind tour
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
since the uk is the birthplace of fly
fishing i thought it only appropriate
that i should do some fly fishing
in england so i went to this private
lake called lechles and bushley's which
has
some amazingly huge trout in it you can
easily catch
a 20 plus pound trout here unfortunately
i came in the wrong time of the year in
the middle of the summer when it was
blistering hot and the water temperature
was so high
that just nobody was there and the trout
were jumping like crazy but they just
wouldn't bite which is a sign that
they're overheated
but i wasn't a waste i got stalking
lessons from a wonderful fishing coach
named george
and he showed me a lot of great tips and
tactics i learned some new things
and he also talked to the owners after
we got done fishing
and let tommy fish in the states
hatchery pond
where you got it come here
tommy come here fish
well done tom not too much no no let it
out a bit tom no
let it out a bit oh well done what a
fisherman all right you can put lockdown
now on the ground already do you want to
put them down
no no no no no no
keep the rod up in the air keep the rod
up walk backwards you walk backwards
the fist will come with you yeah
[Applause]
are you dog was that fun yeah they're so
big they are big ones yeah yeah
let's go clean them
good job tommy
different bus loops of paris today
cherry lakes is
a trophy carp fishing lake and they have
their own tackle shop and gear you can
rent
but also nearby there's a full-blown
tackle shop with
tons of gear that you can't find in the
united states i love just rummaging
around
british tackle shops you get to see all
sorts of weird kit and
tools that you just can't get in the
united states and while i was fishing at
cherry lakes it was really hot and the
carp were
high up in the water column and just
weren't biting and so i decided to try
out
zig bugs which are these little buoyant
flies that you can buy
and so i rigged them up and threw them
out there and they were
absolutely the hot ticket while i was
there
all right tommy show me what you got
okay
again there
you got him tom
looks like he's about 21 21 in change
hey tom over here sit down sit down
there we go
he's swimming away
[Applause]
in the summertime the best time to catch
a carp is usually an hour or two before
sunset to an
hour or two after sunrise so you do a
lot of night fishing so we have these
tents and these bed chairs and you just
camp out by your rods
with these bite arms that wake you up if
there's a fish and then
in the middle of the day you get to go
sightseeing and hang out with your
family
you got a shark
[Music]
in the middle of the day when the fish
weren't biting we did a lot of day trips
and my favorite was going to wales
to go to car philly castle it was
absolutely
amazing we went and got fish and chips
and whales and we got a small
order of fries okay
i foolishly ordered the large fish
so um yeah
there you go the country of wales has
its own dialect its own culture and it's
just an amazing place with tons of these
medieval castles
and car philly castle is one of the best
ones it even has
20 pound carp swimming around the moat
but we had a ball exploring this castle
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
me and becca have a tradition that every
time we visit a country we like to buy
kids books in the language of the
country we're visiting so we went to
this book shop across from the castle
and bought a british kids book
and a welsh kids book and i also bought
some more carp fishing magazines you
know
and we got picked up the kids some toys
we just had a great time in wales
and it was one of those countries that
we really wish we had more time to visit
rather than just day tripping from the
cotswolds
after we got back from wales we had our
first rainy day of the entire
trip and we went back to bibery and saw
more of the beautiful sights and i took
tommy trout fishing because he
loves to catch trout and this little
trout farm they got over there
is just so gorgeous and it's got
everything you need to go and catch a
ton of trout and you can even cook it
right
there you have barbecues and stuff for
grilling the fish right there if you
want
so i took tommy out and we went and
played around
and caught some trout and just had a
wonderful day
i got the nuts
tommy show me your fish that's
goosey mouth it has a gills and mouth
that's right
that's a big trout good job
good job yeah follow grandpa
we really enjoyed catching and cooking
up this crowd
around our cottage there's all these
wild herbs growing like sage and tying
and stuff so we packed that trout full
of herbs
wrapped in tin foil and put some butter
in there and just had a wonderful
trout dinner but i just really enjoyed
fishing at this location all the staff
that worked there and the owner were
great people and they bent over
backwards try to make sure each one of
their guests
had a good time and caught fish and it
was just a wonderful place to visit and
i hope we can go back there sometime
and uh we we had a ball but
all good things have to come to an end
and so it was our last day we had to
eventually pack it up
and call it um but we
weren't done yet on our way back to
london we stopped by the city of windsor
and got to see the queen's castle and do
some shopping
and just had a great time
[Music]
[Music]
these 10 days just flew by and we had
such a great time
we've been to england several times and
if you'd like to see those videos
and along with our other travel and
adventure videos here on the outdoor
boys youtube channel
check out our travel and adventure
playlist i'll put a link in the
description and thanks for watching we
put out new videos
every saturday morning see you then if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching